So years ago, when I was a high school student, I walked away from Christianity.
And I went down a whole other path for a good long time.
The primary reason that I walked away is because
I had questions and I had doubts.
And you've gotten up to this point now where not only have you all this content
and we've talked about love, but we've talked about the power of questions and the
power of conversation.
But somewhere in there at some point, questions from others,
information from other people, going to college, all kinds of different things are
going to be coming at your students, causing doubt.
What happens when they doubt? See, I walked away because I thought, well, because I
was doubting and I asked a question, I was told not to ask the questions.
I was told to just believe. I was told to just have faith and I didn't know what
that even meant and I just couldn't figure it all out so I just said enough
and I walk away.
The statistics are still out there and they're still pretty prevalent that a
large majority of students leave youth group after high school and there's a whole
bunch of reasons for that.
One of them is because when they have doubts, they're not getting answered.
So this is an opportunity to open it up to your students and say, listen, I get it.
I know you have doubts. Maybe share some of your own and that's okay.
Let's talk about them. Let's make sure this is an open forum.
We talked weeks ago, the very beginning of this process, the idea of having an open
communication and having a youth group that was very authentic and very open
and invited the difficult questions.
And we talked about that those difficult questions were going to come.
They're probably going to come even more now, because sometimes the more information
that you have, the more questions you have as a result.
So invite those in. Invite those doubts.
If students are not sure about Jesus, not sure about the existence of God, not sure
about the biblical text, not sure about evil and pain and suffering, not sure
about any of the things we've talked about and maybe some things we haven't talked
about. Because there's a whole bunch of cultural issues that step into this that you
have to help students navigate. And that's where helping students navigate doubt
is an incredibly important thing and an important tool at actually furthering their
faith. Because as they get those things answered, as they feel free to
express those doubts, that tells them that as leaders,
we understand and that we've been there and that it's okay and we're going to walk
with you through those. So for the introduction activity this week, we asked
students literally to write down one question that they've been wrestling with.
Now, you might, as a large group activity, you might actually take and compile some
of those. You might do a Q&A session.
I find Q&A sessions to be incredibly helpful.
I open up the floor to students and just let them ask whatever they want.
And yeah, you get some funny ones.
I get a lot of dinosaur questions and some interesting ones about Adam and Eve.
And those can be fun. You can play around with those a little bit and have some fun
with it. But at the same time, some really good and profound questions will come up.
And the advantage to that is that if one student asks a question and another
student's afraid to ask the same question, the student that was afraid gets their
question answered. And that can be an incredibly important and powerful tool.
So I would encourage you to maybe do that this week or find a way to incorporate
many questions into your large group time.
And then during small group time, you can drill those questions down a little bit
deeper. But make sure as you do that that your small group leaders are adequately
prepared to handle some of the questions.
Based on your situation, the leadership that you have in place, and the volunteers
that you have in place, just make sure that they are equipped to properly answer.
And remind them that it's okay that they don't have an answer to say, I don't have
an answer. And to write those questions down and bring them back and find a way to
get those questions answered specifically.
Another important, powerful tool is your storyteller this week to
have somebody in front of your students that has actually expressed doubt and walked
through it in some way shape or form can be incredibly important that story whatever
they've been through will resonate I'm sure with many of your students so make sure
that you don't need to find the best story or the biggest story or the most
compelling story but just so that students can see that hey I'm not the only one
going through this and I'm I'm not the only one that has, I'm not the only student
dealing with this and I'm not the only person that's ever dealt with this and people
have got through it because some students might just have a little couple of
questions here and there. Other students might be at a significant crisis of faith
in their lives where they need serious direction.
And after all that you've gone through in this study, some of those things may start
to be, you know, coming up to the surface a little bit.
So remind your students
that no matter their questions, no matter the doubts, God can handle it
and that he has given us everything we need to be entirely confident of who
he is, who Jesus is, and what our salvation means.